Let me pull out an old differential
equations textbook I learned from in college,
and let's turn to this funny little exercise
in here that asks the reader to compute e to
the power of At, where A, we're told, is going to
be a matrix, and the insinuation seems to be that
the result will also be a matrix. It then offers
several examples for what you might plug in for A.
Now, taken out of context, putting a matrix in
an exponent like this probably seems like total
nonsense, but what it refers to is an extremely
beautiful operation, and the reason it shows up in
this book is that it’s useful, it's used to solve
a very important class of differential equations.
In turn, given that the universe is often written
in the language of differential equations,
you see it pop up in physics all the time
too, especially in quantum mechanics,
where matrix exponents are littered throughout the
place, they play a particularly prominent role.
This has a lot to do with Shrödinger’s equation,
which we’ll touch on a bit later. And it
also may help in understanding your romantic
relationships, but again, all in due time.
A big part of the reason I want to cover this
topic is that there’s an extremely nice way to
visualize what matrix exponents are actually doing
using flow, that not a lot of people seem to talk
about. But for the bulk of this chapter, let’s
start by laying out what exactly the operation
actually is, and then see if we can get a feel
for what kinds of problems it helps us to solve.
The first thing you should know is that this is
not some bizarre way to multiply the constant e
by itself multiple times; you would be right
to call that nonsense. The actual definition
is related to a certain infinite polynomial
describing for real number powers of e, what
we call its Taylor series. For example, if I took
the number 2 and plugged it into this polynomial,
then as you add more and more terms, each of
which looks like some power of 2 divided by
some factorial...the sum approaches a number
near 7.389, and this number is precisely e*e.
If you increment this input by 1, then somewhat
miraculously no matter where you started from
the effect on the output is always to
multiply it by another factor of e.
For reasons that you're going to see a bit,
mathematicians became interested in plugging
all kinds of things into this polynomial, things
like complex numbers, and for our purposes today,
matrices, even when those objects do
not immediately make sense as exponents.
What some authors do is give this infinite
polynomial the name “exp” when you plug in more
exotic inputs. It's a gentle nod to the connection
that this has to exponential functions in the
case of real numbers, even though obviously
these inputs don't make sense as exponents.
However, an equally common convention is to
give a much less gentle nod to the connection
and just abbreviate the whole thing as e to the
power of whatever object you’re plugging in,
whether that’s a complex number, or a
matrix, or all sorts of more exotic objects.
So while this equation is a theorem for real
numbers, it’s a definition for more exotic inputs.
Cynically, you could call this a blatant
abuse of notation. More charitably,
you might view it as an example of the beautiful
cycle between discovery and invention in math.
In either case, plugging in a matrix, even
to a polynomial, might seem a little strange,
so let’s be clear on what we mean here. The matrix
needs to have the same number of rows and columns.
That way you can multiply it by itself according
to the usual rules of matrix multiplication.
This is what we mean by squaring it.
Similarly, if you were to take that result,
and then multiply it by the original matrix
again, this is what we mean by cubing the matrix.
If you carry on like this, you can take any
whole power of a matrix, it's perfectly sensible.
In this context, powers still mean exactly
what you’d expect, repeated multiplication.
Each term of this polynomial is scaled by 1
divided by some factorial, and with matrices,
all that means is that you multiply each component
by that number. Likewise, it always makes sense to
add two matrices, this is something you again to
term-by-term. The astute among you might ask how
sensible it is to take this out to infinity,
which would be a great question, one that I'm
largely going to postpone the answer to, but I
can show you one pretty fun example here now.
Take this 2x2 matrix that has -π and
π sitting off its diagonal entries.
Let's see what the sum gives. The
first term is the identity matrix,
this is actually what we mean by definition
when we raise a matrix to the 0th power.
Then we add in the matrix itself, which gives
us the pi-off-the-diagonal terms. And then add
half of the matrix squared, and continuing on I’ll
have the computer keep adding more and more terms,
each of which requires taking one more matrix
product to get a new power and adding it to a
running tally. And as it keeps going, it seems to
be approaching a stable value, which is around -1
times the identity matrix. In this sense, we
say the sum equals that negative identity.
By the end of this video, my
hope is that this particular fact
comes to make total sense to you, for any of
you familiar with Euler’s famous identity,
this is essentially the matrix version
of that. It turns out that in general,
no matter what matrix you start with, as
you add more and more terms you eventually
approach some stable value. Though sometimes
it can take quite a while before you get there.
Just seeing the definition like this, in
isolation, raises all kinds of questions.
Most notably, why would mathematicians and
physicists be interested in torturing their
poor matrices this way, what problems are they
trying to solve? And if you’re anything like me,
a new operation is only satisfying when you
have a clear view of what it’s trying to do,
some sense of how to predict the output based on
the input before you actually crunch the numbers.
How on earth could you have predicted
that the matrix with pi off the diagonals
results in the negative identity matrix like this?
Often in math, you should view the definition
not as a starting point, but as a target.
Contrary to the structure of textbooks,
mathematicians do not start by making definitions,
and then listing a lot of theorems and proving
them, and then showing some examples. The process
of discovering math typically goes the other way
around. They start by chewing on specific problems
and then generalizing those problems, then coming
up with constructs that might be helpful in those
general cases. And only then do you write
down a new definition, or extend an old one.
As to what sorts of specific examples might
motivate matrix exponents, two come to mind,
one involving relationships, and other quantum
mechanics. Let’s start with relationships.
Suppose we have two lovers, let's call them
Romeo and Juliet. And let's let x represent
Juliet’s love for Romeo, and y represent
his love for her, both of which are going
to be values that change with time. This is an
example that we actually touched on in chapter 1,
it's based on a Steven Strogatz article,
but it’s okay if you didn’t see that.
The way their relationship works is that the
rate at which Juliet’s love for Romeo changes,
the derivative of this value, is equal to the -1
times Romeo’s love for her. So in other words,
when Romeo is expressing cool disinterest,
that' when Juliet’s feelings actually increase,
whereas if he becomes too infatuated,
her interest will start to fade.
Romeo, on the other hand, is the
opposite, the rate of change of his
love is equal to Juliet’s love. So while Juliet
is mad at him, his affections tend to decrease,
whereas if she loves him,
that's when his feelings grow.
Of course, neither one of these numbers
is holding still; as Romeo’s love
increases in response to Juliet, her equation
continues to apply and drives her love down.
Both of these equations always apply, from
each infinitesimal point in time to the next,
so every slight change to one value immediately
influences the rate of change of the other.
This is a system of differential equations.
It’s a puzzle, where your challenge is to
find explicit functions for x(t) and y(t)
that make both these expressions true.
Now, as systems of differential equations
go, this one is on the simpler side,
enough so that many calculus students
could probably just guess at an answer.
But keep in mind, though, it’s not enough to
find some pair of functions that makes this true;
if you want to actually predict where Romeo
and Juliet end up after some starting point,
you have to make sure that your functions match
the initial set of conditions at time t=0. More to
the point, our actual goal is to systematically
solve more general versions of this equation,
without guessing and checking, and it's that
question that leads us to matrix exponents.
Very often when you have multiple changing
values like this, it’s helpful to package
them together as coordinates of a single
point in a higher-dimensional space.
So for Romeo and Juliet, think of their
relationship as a point in a 2d space,
the x-coordinate capturing Juilet’s
feelings..and the y-coordinate capturing Romeo’s.
Sometimes it’s helpful to picture this
state as an arrow from the origin,
other times just as a point; all that really
matters is that it encodes two numbers. And moving
forward we'll be writing that as a column vector.
And of course, this is all a function of time.
You might picture the rate of change of the state,
the thing that packages together the derivative of
x and the derivative of y, as a kind of velocity
vector in this state space. Something that tugs
on our vector in some direction, and with some
magnitude indicating how quickly it’s changing.
Remember, the rule here is that the rate of
change of x is -y, and the rate of change of y is
x. Set up as vectors like this, we could
rewrite the right-hand side of this equation
as a product of this matrix with the original
vector [x, y]. The top row encodes Juliet’s rule,
and the bottom row encodes Romeo’s rule. So what
we have here is a differential equation telling
us that the rate of change of some vector
is equal to a certain matrix times itself.
In a moment we’ll talk about how matrix
exponentiation solves this kind of equation,
but before that let me show you a simpler way
that we can solve this particular system, one that
uses pure geometry, and it helps set the stage
for visualizing matrix exponents a bit later.
This matrix from our system is
a 90-degree rotation matrix.
For any of you a bit rusty on how to
think of matrices as transformations,
there’s a video all about it on this
channel, a series really. The basic
idea is that when you multiply a matrix by the
vector [1, 0], it pulls out the first column.
And similarly, if you multiply it by [0, 1]
that pulls out the second column. What this
means is that when you look at a matrix, you
can read its columns as telling you what it
does to these two vectors, known as the basis
vectors. The way it acts on any other vector
is a result of scaling and adding these two
basis results by that vector’s coordinates.
So, looking back at the matrix from our system,
notice how from its columns we can tell
it takes the first basis vector to [0, 1],
and the second to [-1, 0], hence why I’m
calling it the 90-degree rotation matrix.
What it means for our equation is that it's saying
wherever Romeo and Juliet are in this state space,
their rate of change has to look like a
90-degree rotation of this position vector.
The only way velocity can be permanently
perpendicular to position like this
is when you rotate about the origin
in circular motion. Never growing nor
shrinking because the rate of change has
no component in the direction of position.
More specifically, since the length of this
velocity vector equals the length of the
position vector, then for each unit of time, the
distance that this covers is equal to one radius’s
worth of arc length along that circle. In other
words, it rotates at one radian per unit time;
so in particular, it would take 2pi
units of time to make a full revolution.
If you want to describe this kind of
rotation with a formula, we can use a more
general rotation matrix, which looks like this.
Again, we can read it in terms of the columns.
Notice how the first column tells us that it
takes the first basis vector to [cos(t), sin(t)],
and the second column tells us that
it takes the second basis vector
to [-sin(t), cos(t)], both of which are
consistent with rotating by t radians.
So to solve the system, if you want to predict
where Romeo and Juilet end up after t units of
time, you can multiply this matrix by their
initial state. The active viewers among you
may also enjoy taking a moment to pause and
confirm that explicit formulas you get for x(t)
and y(t) really do satisfy the system of
differential equations that we started with.
The mathematician in you might wonder if it’s
possible to solve not just this specific system,
but equations like it for any matrix. To
ask this question is to set yourself up to
rediscover matrix exponents. The main goal for
today is for you to understand how this equation
lets you intuitively picture this operation
which we write as e raised to a matrix, and
on the flip side how being able to compute matrix
exponents lets you explicitly solve this equation.
A much less whimsical example
is Shrödinger’s famous equation,
which is the fundamental equation describing
how systems in quantum mechanics change
over time. It looks pretty intimidating, and I
mean, it’s quantum mechanics so of course it will,
but it’s actually not that different from the
Romeo-Juliet setup. This symbol here refers to
a certain vector. It's a vector that packages
together all the information you might care
about in a system, like the various particles’
positions and momenta. It's analogous to our
simpler 2d vector that encoded all the information
about Romeo and Juliet. The equation says that
the rate at which this state vector changes
looks like a certain matrix times itself.
There are a number of things making Shrödinger’s
equation notably more complicated. But in the
back of your mind you might think of this as a
target point that you and I can build up to, with
simpler examples like Romeo and Juliet offering
more friendly stepping stones along the way.
Actually, the simplest example, which is
tied to ordinary real-number powers of e,
is the one-dimensional case. This is when you
have a single changing value, and its rate of
change equals some constant times itself. So
the bigger the value, the faster it grows.
Most people are more comfortable visualizing
this with a graph, where the higher the value
of the graph, the steeper its slope, resulting in
this ever-steepening upward curve. Just keep in
mind that when we get to higher dimensional
variants, graphs are a lot less helpful.
This is a highly important equation in its
own right. It's a very powerful concept
when the rate of change of a value
is proportional to the value itself.
This is the equation governing
things like compound interest,
or the early stages of population growth before
the effects of limited resources kicks in,
or the early stages of an epidemic while
most of the population is susceptible.
Calculus students all learn about how the
derivative of e^(rt) is r times itself. In
other words, this self-reinforcing growth
is the same thing as exponential growth,
and e^(rt) solves this equation. Actually, a
better way to think about it is that there are
many different solutions to this equation, one
for each initial condition, something like an
initial investment size or initial population,
which we'll just call x0. Notice, by the way,
how the higher the value for x0, the higher
the initial slope of the resulting solution,
which should make complete
sense given the equation.
The function e^(rt) is just a solution when the
initial condition is 1. But! If you multiply by
any other initial condition, you get a new
function that still satisfies the property,
it still has a derivative which is r times
itself. But this time it starts at x0,
since e^0 is 1. This is worth highlighting
before we generalize to more dimensions:
Do not think of the exponential
part as a solution in and of itself.
Think of it as something which acts on an
initial condition in order to give a solution.
You see, up in the 2-dimensional case,
when we have a changing vector whose
rate of change is constrained
to be some matrix times itself,
what the solution looks like is also an
exponential term acting on a given initial
condition. But the exponential part, in that case,
will produce a matrix that changes with time,
and the initial condition is a vector. In
fact, you should think of the definition of
matrix exponentiation as being heavily
motivated by making sure this is true.
For example, if we look back at the system that
popped up with Romeo and Juliet, the claim now is
that solutions look like e raised to this [[0,
-1], [1, 0]] matrix all times time, multiplied
by some initial condition. But we’ve already seen
the solution in this case, we know it looks like a
rotation matrix times the initial condition. So
let’s take a moment to roll up our sleeves and
compute the exponential term using the definition
I mentioned at the start, and see if it lines up.
Remember, writing e to the power of a matrix is
a shorthand, a shorthand for plugging it into
this long infinite polynomial, the Taylor
series of e^x. I know it might seem pretty
complicated to do this, but trust me, it’s very
satisfying how this particular one turns out.
If you actually sit down and you compute
successive powers of this matrix,
what you’d notice is that they fall into
a cycling pattern every four iterations.
This should make sense, given that we
know it’s a 90-degree rotation matrix.
So when you add together all
infinitely many matrices term-by-term,
each term in the result looks like a polynomial
in t with some nice cycling pattern in the
coefficients, all of them scaled by the relevant
factorial term. Those of you who are savvy with
Taylor series might be able to recognize that
each one of these components is the Taylor
series for either sine or cosine, though in that
top right corner's case it’s actually -sin(t).
So what we get from the computation is exactly
the rotation matrix we had from before!
To me, this is extremely beautiful. We have two
completely different ways of reasoning about the
same system and they give us the same answer.
I mean it’s reassuring that they do, but it
is wild just how different the mode of thought
is when you're chugging through the polynomial
vs. when you're geometrically reasoning about what
a velocity perpendicular to a position must imply.
Hopefully the fact that these line
up inspires a little confidence
in the claim that matrix exponents
really do solve systems like this.
This explains the computation we saw at the
start, by the way, with the matrix that had
-π and π off the diagonal, producing the negative
identity. This expression is exponentiating
a 90-degree rotation matrix times π, which is
another way to describe what the Romeo-Juliet
setup does after π units of time. As we
now know, that has the effect of rotating
everything by 180-degrees in this state space,
which is the same as multiplying everything by -1.
Also, for any of you familiar
with imaginary number exponents,
this example is probably ringing a ton of bells.
It is 100% analogous. In fact, we could have
framed the entire example where Romeo and Juliet’s
feelings were packaged into a complex number,
and the rate of change of that complex
number would have been i times itself since
multiplication by i also acts like a 90-degree
rotation. The same exact line of reasoning,
both analytic and geometric, would have led to
this whole idea that e^(it) describes rotations.
There are actually two of many different
examples throughout math and physics
when you find yourself exponentiating some
object which acts as a 90-degree rotation,
times time. It shows up with quaternions or many
of the matrices that pop up in quantum mechanics.
In all of these cases, we have this really neat
general idea that if you take some operation
that rotates 90-degrees in some plane, often
it's a plane in some high-dimensional space
we can’t visualize, then what we get by
exponentiation that operation times time
is something that generates all
other rotations in that same plane.
One of the more complicated variations on
this same theme is Shrödinger’s equation.
It’s not just that it has the
derivative-of-a-state-equals-some-matrix-times-that-state
form. The nature of the relevant matrix
here is such that this equation also describes
a kind of rotation, though in many applications
of Schrödinger's equation it will be a
rotation inside a kind of function space.
It’s a little more involved, though, because
typically there's a combination of many different
rotations. It takes time to really dig into
this equation, and I’d love to do that in a
later chapter. But right now I cannot help but at
least allude to the fact that this imaginary unit
i that sits so impishly in such a fundamental
equation for all of the universe, is playing
basically the same role as the matrix from our
Romeo-Juilet example. What this i communicates
is that the rate of change of a certain state
is, in a sense, perpendicular to that state,
and hence that the way things have to evolve
over time will involve a kind of oscillation.
But matrix exponentiation can do
so much more than just rotation.
You can always visualize these sorts of
differential equations using a vector field.
The idea is that this equation tells us that the
velocity of a state is entirely determined by its
position. So what we do is go to every point in
this space, and draw a little vector indicating
what the velocity of a state must be if it passes
through that point. For our type of equation,
this means that we go to each point v in
space, and we attach the vector M times v.
To intuitively understand how any given initial
condition will evolve, you let it flow along this
field, with a velocity always matching whatever
vector it’s sitting on at any given point in time.
So if the claim is that solutions to this equation
look like e^(Mt) times some initial condition,
it means you can visualize what the matrix
e^(Mt) does by letting every possible
initial condition flow along this field for
t units of time. The transition from start
to finish is described by whatever matrix
pops out from the computation for e^(Mt).
In our main example with the 90-degree rotation
matrix, the vector field looks like this,
and as we saw e^(Mt) describes rotation in that
case, which lines up with flow along this field.
As another example, the more Shakesperian
Romeo and Juliet might have equations
that look a little more like this, where
Juliet’s rule is symmetric with Romeo’s,
and both of them are inclined to get carried
away in response to one and others feelings.
Again, the way the vector field you’re looking
at has been defined is to go to each point v in
space and attach the vector M times v. This is the
pictorial way of saying that the rate of change of
a state must always equal M times itself. But for
this example, flow along the vector field looks a
lot different from how it did before. If Romeo
and Juliet start anywhere in this upper-right
half of the plane, their feelings will feed off
of each other and they both tend towards infinity.
If they're in the other half of the plane, well,
let’s just say they stay more true to their
Capulet and Montague family traditions.
So even before you try calculating the exponential
of this particular matrix, you can already have an
intuitive sense of what the answer should look
like. The resulting matrix should describe the
transition from time 0 to time t, which, if you
look at the field, seems to indicate that it will
squish along one diagonal while stretching along
another, getting more extreme as t gets larger.
Of course, all of this is presuming that e^(Mt)
times an initial condition actually solves these
systems. This is one of those facts that’s easiest
to believe when you just work it out yourself.
But I’ll run through a quick rough sketch.
Write out the full polynomial that defines e^(Mt),
and multiply by some initial
condition vector on the right.
And then take the derivative
of this with respect to t.
Because M is a constant, this just means
applying the power rule to each one of the terms.
And that power rule really nicely
cancels out with the factorial terms.
So what we're left with is an expression that
looks almost identical to what we had before,
except that every term has
an extra M hanging on to it.
But this can be factored out to the left.
So the derivative of this expression
is M times the original expression,
and hence it solves the equation.
This actually sweeps under the rug some details
required for rigor, mostly centered around the
question of whether or not this thing actually
converges, but it does give the main idea.
In the next chapter, I would like to talk more
about the properties that this operation has,
most notably its relationship
with eigenvectors and eigenvalues,
which leads us to more concrete ways of thinking
about how you actually carry out the computation,
which otherwise seems insane. Also,
time permitting, it might be fun to
talk about what it means to raise e to
the power of the derivative operator.